just
on cash money west obviously blue face
comes after kind of blows up the brand
but like
was it whack or was it birdman who was
who who who's like a
radar did you get on first i guess he's
definitely whack everything is wack you
know i'm saying
he seen me
he seen me um doing a little freestyle
like on my real come up you know she
didn't see me doing a card freestyle
um
he was following one of my one of my
homies and they posted it he seen it
boom and reached out and uh in the
beginning when he was telling me like
man birdman gave me the keys
uh to start cash money west and find
whatever i want i didn't really believe
him you know what i'm saying but well
hey i'm gonna say this about whack man
i i've never witnessed whack
lie i've known whack for a long time
he'll say some [ __ ] that you'd be like
yeah
yeah yeah he exaggerated but he ain't
gonna lie he on our show is where he's
talking about the second sex tape with
ray j hill yeah
and everybody's like nah full of [ __ ]
full of [ __ ] and look she's talking she
was talking about it on the new [ __ ]
uh kardashian show she was stressed out
because it was it existed black knows
some [ __ ] oh he knows some [ __ ] man i'm
telling you don't play with him you know
that [ __ ] got secret he's got a lot he
knows you know nigga's secret he does
yeah whack his head he's gonna leave it
there i love whack i love wack though
for sure i always i think wax one of the
more uh brilliant
guys in the music industry and i say
that and i truly mean it i know some i
know he's he's you know he's
wack's gonna whack
whether it's there's always a new
[ __ ] headline
he needs to stay the [ __ ] off clubhouse
i've told him this why are you on
clubhouse every day just yeah like right
now you're rich you talking right now
yeah
but like when you see like him like
start to like link up with like a six
nine like does that like does that you
know because obviously you're cut from a
whole different cloth right i mean uh
and i understand his position it's a
whole different this is that street
business entertainment business i get it
yeah man you know what i'm saying we at
me and wack we come from the same
backgrounds you know what i'm saying
like when you when you're growing up we
got the uh locked up yeah one time yeah
we applied the same code applied to us
but when it comes to business
why he do what he do you know what i'm
saying we as long as ain't got nothing
to do with me is good
i ain't gonna
uh
base my decisions or my moves off
nothing that he'd do with somebody else
for nothing or or judge it or whatever
because that's what he doing you know
what i'm saying at the end of the day he
ain't got nothing to do with me what uh
ended up kind of bringing you two back
together uh out because there was
definitely some static
yeah um
at the end of the day i
i grew up and realized that
it'll be it'll be more in my best
interest to to to
you know make things right at the end of
the day because i knew it was me and he
took a chance on you period i think
at the end of everything it takes a big
man to yeah i know it was me own some
[ __ ] it was ultimately me
like you know i just
i didn't have my hat on straight
and i'm you know
what's uh why not give it another chance
if it ain't if it ain't too broken you
know what i'm saying so
we made [ __ ] right i had to make sure
right